since the first x-men movie all the way
back in 2000 the architects of the
franchise have been dropping in small
nods and references to the comics that
inspired the film's Dark Phoenix
continues the tradition and some big and
not so big Easter eggs for the
eagle-eyed and comics versed here are
some you may have blinked and missed on
your first watch and if you haven't seen
the movie here's your warning spoilers
are ahead Dark Phoenix opens with a
tragic scene set in 1975 a pivotal year
for the x-men with the release of
giant-size x-men number one an issue
that single-handedly revitalized a
flagging Marvel franchise by bringing on
characters including Nightcrawler
Colossus and Wolverine the guy you might
have heard of before the scene turns
tragic and the greys crashed their car
an argument over what's on the radio
leads to two significant songs being
played as Jean telekinetically turns the
dial the first is the 1967 Glen Campbell
version of by the time I get to Phoenix
which should be pretty self-explanatory
the other is a little deeper in its
meaning it's werewolves of London by
Warren Zevon which was released three
years later in 1978 making it an
anachronism it seemed a reference to the
first issue of Excalibur titled war
wolf's of London
that series saw a ragtag team of former
x-men including the Rachel summers
version of Phoenix and Nightcrawler
carrying on in the United Kingdom after
they believed the rest of the team to be
dead Excalibur also stars Kitty Pryde
who seemingly makes a very quick cameo
phasing through a wall late in the movie
the movies present-day setting as it
were is 1992 the year the popular x-men
cartoon series started but while the
early 90s weren't exactly associated
with disco we still get an appearance
from the disco dancing mutant Dazzler
Dazzler belts out some dance tunes at
the outdoor party celebrating the
mission to save the NASA astronauts from
certain doom on the space shuttle
Endeavour
which notably did have its first mission
in may 1992 though she's a superhero
herself in the comics Dazzler doesn't
seem to be much more than the x-men's
personal party singer here speaking of
very specific jobs the party scene also
includes a quick appearance by recent
x-men recruit match who lights a fire
like Phoenix
got a bit of a temper it wouldn't be too
surprising if you missed the name of an
alien race that served as dark Phoenix's
ultimate antagonists since it's only
mentioned once in the whole movie
they're the d'bari a race of aliens who
in the comics look kind of like
asparagus they've appeared in a number
of comic stories over the years first in
Avengers number four and sometimes as
villains but for the purposes of Dark
Phoenix their most important appearance
was in uncanny x-men number 135 in which
a Phoenix possessed Jean Grey destroys
their home planet that association with
the Phoenix force is basically where the
movie d'bari similarities to the comic
characters end the shape-shifting powers
in the film are much more like Scrolls
jessica chastain plays the d'bari leader
who is also very different in the comics
they can't begin to comprehend what you
are even your x-men instead of desiring
the Phoenix force for the purposes of
creating new worlds the d'bari leader in
comics Luke simply wants to attack Jean
Grey and get revenge for the destruction
of his home planet he gets a pretty
sweet suit of armor and adopts the name
star hammer in one attempt but is not
successful time traveller professional
rebel part-time sleuth and all-around
cool guy Lucas Bishop actually appeared
in one x-men movie 2014's Days of Future
past he died in that movie but then his
death got erased when the timeline
changed at the end of that movie he only
manages to return in dark Phoenix in the
name of the Red Hook area electrical
utility in the scene where the x-men
arrived to confront Jean in the
neighborhood where she grew up after she
discovers her father is still alive a
truck emblazoned with the words
Bishop power is visible in the
background of several shots that may be
a nod to bishops mutant abilities while
they're not specifically electrical in
nature he can absorb and release various
forms of energy or who knows maybe the
movie version of Lucas bishops family
decided to found a public utility and
the future version of him will just run
that it's good work if you can get it
the magneto of Dark Phoenix is more or
less retired he tells Jean that he has
essentially decided that hurting people
won't do him any good anymore
so he stopped with all that giving up
his violent ways from the previous films
and opting to live on a secluded Island
that's a haven for mutants who just want
to get away from it all it's a
simple community built from old shipping
containers and other junk magneto has
likely pulled out of the ocean with his
powers this land was given to us by the
US government we have no intention of
taking it back not here for you
Magneto's new homeland isn't given a
name in the movie but it seems to be a
version of Genosha an island mutant
homeland from the comics the comics
version however is a much more imposing
place initially it was a nation where
mutants were enslaved but the x-men
toppled its regime while saving allies
in prison there later the United Nations
gave control of the country to magneto
who made it a mutants only nation it's
been the site of numerous conflicts
since then there are not many jokes in
Dark Phoenix there are almost zero
comedic moments despite earlier movies
in the franchise having a good bed of
comic relief remember when Wolverine
verified that he wasn't mystique when
Cyclops asked him about it in the first
movie it's me prove it you're a dick ok
Dark Phoenix totally plays it straight
but there's one thing he could
definitely call a sort of meta joke in
the new universe where Disney has merged
20th Century Fox as some viewers noticed
in the trailers the paramilitary group
that apprehends the x-men near the end
of the movie goes by the initials MCU
according to the patches on their
sleeves it likely stands for something
like mutant control unit in the cartoon
this organization is called the mutant
Control Agency but it's clear the
filmmakers wanted to change that one
letter to have a little fun a heavily
militarized group using futuristic
weapons and going by the initials MCU
takes these 20th Century Fox versions of
mutants away to reprogram and bend them
to their will that sure seems like some
kind of metaphor for something but also
they're not all bad when the real bad
guys attack it team up with the x-men so
that's nice
following genes sacrifice at the end of
the climactic battle we see that Charles
Xavier has moved on to live a life of
playing chess outside of cafes Hank
McCoy now staying in his beast form has
taken over as headmaster of the school
and he's given it a new name the Jean
Grey school for gifted youngsters
it's his tribute to her for choosing a
path of light and they
not so subtle jab at his old mentor the
school has born jeans name in the comics
too in the series Wolverine and the
x-men new headmasters Wolverine and
Kitty Pryde renamed the school the Jean
Grey school of higher learning after
Professor X's death one of many he has
endured in that instance it's less of a
slight toward Xavier and more of an
indication of a new generation of
students at the school which would of
course bear xavier z' name again a few
years later check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]